on en vient à cette nouvelle médiation
dans la crise entre la russie et
l'ukraine le président turc et aide à
kiev ce jeudi raid cheptel père de yoann
affiche son soutien aux ukrainiens mais
il ne veut pas irrité moscou bonjour
ludovic du foucault vous avez suivi
cette rencontre c'est un exercice
d'équilibriste commençant les sorties
président turc
bonjour julien houle effectivement c'est
un chemin de crête mais le président
aventure que c'est clairement rendu à
kiev en tant que faiseur de paix en tant
que médiateur bien sûr il en a profité
aussi pour signer des contrats qui
portent notamment sur la coopération de
défense qui lie son pays la turquie à
l'ukraine coopération qui concerne
notamment l'acquisition par l'ukraine et
elle a déjà fait deux drones de
fabrication turc et il ya même une usine
de maintenance de ces drones qui sortira
de terre en ukraine il faut comprendre
que selon le président turc la turquie
est légitime a joué un rôle important
dans la région et donc notamment
l'ukraine en tant que pays riverains de
la mer noire et parce qu'il ya en
ukraine la présence d'une minorité de
culture turcique les tatars et donc vous
l'avez dit le président turc joue ce
rôle maintenant de médiateur il a invité
les présidents ukrainien et russe à une
rencontre bilatérale chez lui en turquie
et il faut dire que pour le président
turc idi a clairement un coup à jouer
parce que s'ils arrivent à se
montrer sur la scène internationale
comme celui qui aura évité une offensive
comme le faiseur de paix celui qui évite
les guerres il pourra vraiment redorer
son blason et le blason de son pays la
turquie vis-à-vis surtout des américains
et donc essayer de sortir la turquie de
l'impasse diplomatique dans laquelle
elle se trouve actuellement de l'
isolement diplomatique dans laquelle
elle dans l'acte dans laquelle elle se
trouve actuellement mais tout cela est
un pari risqué parce que cela pourrait
évidemment irrité la russie la turquie
et la russie ont une bonne relation
c'est une relation de coopération mais
aussi de rivalités dans de nombreuses
régions du monde merci beaucoup ludovic
de foucault pour ces précisions